[Musique]
premier jour de l'ifa première greffe
c'est la course d'un cerf ce matin on va
y voir un petit peu ce qui se passe les
nouveautés qu'est-ce que acer va nous
raconter pour cette histoire c'est
plutôt coup parce que ça c'est la grande
rentrée on peut reprendre la salle de
classe pour certains le bancs de la fac
pour d'autres et pour moi on commence
par berlin ya quand même pire plein de
choses à voir place aux couleurs on
commence par acer et il y aura plein de
choses plein de choses dont vous invite
ce n'est pas déjà le cas à vous abonner
comme ça vous sauver
[Musique]
j
on est allé karim wade sur le stand d'à
série et ce matin la conf de presse
présente un peu nouvelle directrice pour
ce deuxième semestre 2010 la bêtise un
tube à exactement on est au top des
nouveaux produits nouveaux tricks de 5
suite cinq types dont 300 pour le riz
plateforme online
voilà pas mal de nouveautés et concepts
et oui concept des rochers proposer
enfin petit ou ouais tu montes les
nouveaux produits oui et puis on restera
tout ça plus tard
[Musique]
chantôme sur la partie sud 5 oui c'est
le nouveau fer de lance des modèles
grand public qui 10 août 5 10 pc super
légers avec l'âne alliage de carbone la
nouveauté c'est que les bords sur
l'ultra fin il est bien évidemment
toujours tactile - ce qui était assez
taxés comme celui-ci et 990 grammes donc
sur une année les jeunes et et bien
qu'il soit super légers on reste sur le
top en tant que composant donc on est
sur un processeur core i7 de 10e
génération dixième génération z tout
nouveau cross etel beaucoup plus rapide
plus performants meilleure autonomie
mais en gestion d'énergie donc on est un
modèle qui peut aller jusqu'à 12h30 de
batterie ok donc en charge
la veille et on passe la journée avec
sans problème stop c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui
ce qui était intéressant et en plus de
ça
de par un besoin du chargeur qui tue
on pèse presque plus lourd que le pc et
puis à une carte graphique geforce mx
250 qui est intégré ouais mais en
fonction des configurations il peut y
avoir une cpu intégré large et plus
directement écho concert concept décès
la nouvelle gamme que l'on a développé
qui est dédié aux créateurs tels que ce
soit et à graphistes du motion design
des programmes et enfin tous ceux qui
ont besoin de machines super puissante
pour travailler avec d'accord mais en
fait on s'est rendu compte que beaucoup
d utilisateurs de viande predators
étaient en fait des créateurs utiliser
du predator dans leur métier et ont du
coup se dit pas pourquoi pas leur dédier
des machines qu'ils soient pas du gaming
mais qui prennent tout ce qu'ils aiment
dans les pc gaming et y ajouter ce dont
ils ont besoin
les ponts du coup ça a généré du concept
d et on a des machines avec des écrans
qui ont un delta inférieur à 2 qui ont
des certifications pantone ou adobe rgb
donc vraiment d'une colorimétrie qui est
fidèle à ce que j'imprime ce que je vois
l'image la couleur est fidèle à ce que
je vais imprimer mais que c'est mon
imprimeur où on a dû utiliser les techno
que la développer sur la partie des
mines ont les incorporer dedans idem
pour le refroidissement les machines ne
dépasse pas les 40 décibels
en open space c'est parfait sinon
paraît-il à paris voir des faits
exactement là où un gamer du coup là peu
plus ventilé puisque c'est dans l'adn du
pc gaming de ventiler pour garder la
carte au max là on n'aura pas besoin
donc derrière c'est surtout l'écran qui
va être important et la colorimétrie est
juste génial donc du père italien
c'est quoi il ya plus spécifique des
neuf mois le des neuf c'est la machine
ultime pour les créateurs
en gros c'est l'équivalent de sa tour
que l'on peut utiliser ou alors de la
tablette
vous aimez dans l'une des spécificités
c'est que l'écran que se rabat pour
pouvoir approcher ou l'utiliser en
format tablette ont dessiné dessus
donc on est sur une machine picarde
puissante plus conditions du core i9
d'accord est pareil sur de la cua gros
mais sur un écran 4 cas donc après avec
toujours les spécificités comme des
locations pantone doivent être gérés
donc c'est vraiment la machine que vous
y soyez a surtout les compatible avec un
stylo wacom d'accord sont utilisés par
les tablettes donc vraiment là on est
sur une très très très près
ces belles machines très puissantes
celui là c'est tout le refroidissement
exactement
en fait des ventilos pour sur le côté
à l'arrière d'accord plutôt si
le fait de rapprocher l'écran ap d'avoir
l'air circule qui parlait de marc
derrière derrière l'écran dans les
grands tition de calcul de rendu de
calcul 3d à ce moment là forcément
intergraphic au processeur
les verts font chauffer ça permet de
maintenir des performances et un silence
optimale donc l'installer la nouvelle
version but de ces chronos l'église a
exactement le kronos terre qui est la
nouvelle version du kronos et vous avez
une nouvelle version qui ont plus
s'écouter des massages or l'idée c'est
de dire énormément hyper énergique aller
retour ils ont joué là fabien basculer
sur un système de bascule comme celui de
massage en tête ne pas prendre ma tâche
de l'ariège depuis qu'elle a l'air
vachement ma part une expérience
d'immersion envoyé au centre est tout
sauf truc est hyper cool alors c'est
parti pour tout le monde mais c'est
plutôt qu'une équipe comme ça c'est un
produit qu'on retrouvera dans le grand
public face à un produit qui est rond
particulier qu'il faut avoir s'il avait
demandé je pense à les contacter
directement là bas
en fait je veux dire que c'est sur
demande mais c'est un produit en édition
collector oui déjà et qui a un certain
prix donc c'est pas vraiment destiné à
tout le monde de sueur mais alors quel
est celui qui vous veut en acheter leurs
plus beaux costumes complets alors
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit monsieur qatar
pour le risque ne serait pris en compte
à vue le mondial à davos sur les cours
internationaux impression 1399 euros
juin de choper l'inflation jeunes bravo
l'intrus connaître abricots en cours la
partie des mines du coup pour la partie
des mines présentent le triton 300 way
qui est le petit frère du sud 105 100
d'accord donc très haut de gamme à ses
fins pour du gaming
car châssis en aluminium
on est là sur un pc équipé en gtx et 50
hockey contre les gars graphique assez
intéressante pour le genre mobilité
et derrière donc ça qu'un s'il tiendrait
que 6 pouces avec un écran mat
antireflet mais sur des core i7 avec un
écran soit 44 hertz et 3 min secondes le
temps de réponse
ok sur une super belle machine très
élégante
qu'ils puissent qui peut être emporté
partout et qui peut être utilisée pour
jouer ou même pour travailler un peu et
je vais de temps en temps donc c'est
hyper hyper intéressant quand machine
d'accord ok donc là tu t'adresses
vraiment dialoguer mais leur nature à
mon bâton franc du collier mais c'est
entre les deux entre les deux puisque il
ya la partie cage où l'on veut un pc un
peu élégant un peu sympa peut-être peut
travailler dessus et du coup sortir la
fac ou même dans son île boulot contre
les finances travaille dessus
et le soir on se fait partie haute de
temps en temps donc c'est à une machine
très équilibré et après pour le joueur
qui a un petit peu plus hardcore qui
peut league of legends ou fortnight ou
pib g c'est super on peut jouer dessus à
fond et on est sur deux 54 3 me seront
donc on n'a pas de nappes à deux pas de
souci en terme de performance et de
plaisir passe mais aussi sur la machine
on a le predator scène ce qui lui permet
de régler deux géants fait de voir tous
la machine de la température la
fréquence
la vitesse des ventilateurs de rotation
des ventilateurs pourquoi et surtout
aussi contrôler toutes les zones
d'éclairage d'italie on peut le
personnaliser
c'est vraiment intéressant puisque on a
aussi ajouté la synchronisation part je
regrette en fonction du jeu les réglages
peuvent être pré défini donc quand je
lance mon jeu mon clavier skies une
certaine couleur certaine que je peux
sorte la ventilation d'une certaine
manière c'est un lexique intéressant et
est aussi bénéficier de la quatrième
génération de ventilo aéro blade donc
design est en aluminium et qui
permettent un meilleur refroidissement
non c'est aussi un réseau social pour
les guillemets oui plett 9 les néo cons
qui voient la volonté en fait à la base
du métier d'aller plus loin que
seulement là
la fabrication de machines ou du
hardware d'accord c'est vraiment d'être
dans l'écosystème et de dd l'écosystème
aussi à se développer
il ya toute une partie sur le site qui
est consacré plus haut aux joueurs qui
veulent monter leur équipe alors des
statistiques sur la manière de jouer
ou est-ce qu'il va s'améliorer et en
fait à partir de ces statistiques le
site
un algorithme on peut proposer le bon
coach pour permettre d'améliorer tel ou
tel élément ses fils et après donc des
joueurs aguerris vont pouvoir coacher
des joueurs en club à gagner sur
certaines fonctionnalités présentes
avant oui performant ce qu'ils ont dans
leur jeu de prédilection et avec des
équipes entières peuvent être coaché par
un coach via la plate forme d'accord et
ce qui est intéressant c'est les outils
derrière où le coach peut voir l'écran
des autres joueurs et directement y
intégrer des annotations votre à
distance on peut encerclé un ennemi ou
mettre une flèche pour dire voilà là où
j'aurais dû déplacer son cours magistral
sont en face on devra et le joueur voit
ça en live c'est hyper intuitive
alors j'imagine que le coaching
génération comment ça marche en fait le
coach s'enregistrent plateforme va dire
voilà moi je suis coach sur tel ou tel
jeu donc voilà là où je peux vous aider
à vous améliorer
et il va mettre ses honoraires mais
ensuite il est dans
sorte de catalogue de coach et soit un
joueur qui veut s'améliorer va avoir des
recommandations par l'algorithme dire
tel ou tel coach posséder ou alors le
joueur peut choisir et prendre le coach
qui hérisse que le coach doit avoir
joint certain nombre d'heures compte
bien prouver qu'il sait faire
moi ce que ces vies qui n'ont ni les
compétences là dedans je crayon
normalement c'est lui qui fait qu'ils
s'enregistrent seul à rêver
on ne va pas épatant position - salariat
non on était content
il ya des commentaires les
les ratings les étoiles donc oui un bon
coach ressortira toujours et un mauvais
coach entre guillemets identifiés sur un
total de 106 tonnes c'est vraiment toi
quand tu sais maman parce
qu'effectivement on se dira c est là
vous êtes fabricants oui hélas vous
passez les acteurs en fait oui oui c'est
un fait ça fait partie de tout notre
investissement gaming puis aussi des
tournois que l'on organise notre
anticipation à des retours des
internationaux
d'après dr ligue en asie les yeux m en
europe le partenariat créé n'gbo on a
annoncé aussi la musique ce donc
d'accord c'est pas seulement des
machines mais c'est aussi mon vrai les
participations l'écosystème et
ray support pour le développement
c'est quelque chose qui nous plaît
énormément et on nous a semblé naturel
bon voilà pour cette découverte peu du
côté de chez acer on va ressortir la
leaf en train de se monter
si vous voyez c'est en train de bricoler
vous avez des voeux celle de tous les
côtés parce que je retiens vraiment sur
le lancement grand public c'est vraiment
la soul the saints qui rajoute une
bécane qui est top dans la gamme très
léger à très sympa donc c'est vachement
cool
après si vous aimez le gaming
effectivement il ya ce qu'il faut de
côté de chez les predators le côté
professionnel à des concepts d et puis
surtout le truc un petit peu what the
fuck mais qui est palestinien tout le
monde sait ce réseau social pour les
gamers son sac au dos je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas juste en dessous en
commentaire
est ce que vous êtes utilisateur de a
certes son predator ou sera c'est un
plus je dirais grand public
ou est-ce que même pour usage
professionnel ça pourrait vous tentez
notamment concept d et puis pourquoi pas
d'autres produits de la gamme mark et
moi tout ça en bas on en parle ensemble
on se testera très bientôt cette swift 5
je pense que ça va j'ai failli me casser
la gueule sauf que ça va être cool voilà
sur ce jeu fait des gros bisous je vous
donne rendez vous dès demain ça y est
c'est parti c'est la rentrée on est là
pour continuer à parler paix qui voit là
oui il vise le top